you know the airlines are celebrating
women's history month and uh here's a
quick
Tick Tock another Tick Tock video this
one's from Delta and their women's
History Month celebration let's watch
this did somebody say slay
[Music]
okay that was it that was the whole
thing so that was uh is a bunch of young
female Delta airline pilots and
mechanics and
flight attendants dancing and uh and lip
syncing
and you know you know this fills me with
visceral Terror I have to admit um and
it's it's it's not because I'm sexist
against female airline pilots
I mean I am as I've admitted but I also
want to make clear that uh that that
it's okay because I'm also ageist okay
when it comes to airline pilots young
airline pilots terrify me as well
as I've said many times every airline
pilot should be a man between the ages
of 40 and I'll say 65
and I believe they should all have
mustaches every pilot should look like
you know a version of Captain Sully the
land of the Planet of the Hudson that
that is the classic airline pilot look
and that's what I'm looking for it makes
me feel more comfortable
I was on a plane the other day and there
was a there was a young guy in the
cockpit I try not to even look you know
if I when I'm walking in and the door's
still open you can see the pile so I try
not to even look anymore because I'm I'm
most the time these days I'm terrified
by what I see I happen to glance in and
the guy he looked like he was just out
of Middle School like this was his they
just took the training wheels off and
I'm on his first flight
and I get they got to start somewhere
but just don't start on the plane that
I'm flying on is my point
but my other issue with this kind of
thing is uh
this marketing strategy of Airlines and
you see a lot of this
it's not just like the wokeness it's
also the the lack of seriousness okay
what happened to seriousness in our
culture
I don't want an airline advertising
itself with lip syncing and dancing I I
just I don't
videos from an airline I want a little
bit of seriousness cheerful okay you
don't want gloomy you don't want your
airline to be gloomy but you want
a a cheerful but serious disposition
from your airline I would say
that's what we're missing in our society
in general but especially
with Airlines
[Music]
[Applause]